if you're weirded out by cognition in
Plants you're not ready for exobiology
right if if you know something that's
that similar here on Earth is already
like freaking you out then I think
there's going to be all kinds of
cognitive life out there that we're
gonna have a really hard time
recognizing
I think robots will help us yeah
like expand our mind about cognition
either that or the word like xenobots so
and they maybe becomes the same thing is
you know really when the human Engineers
the thing at least in part and then is
able to achieve some kind of cognition
that's different than what you're used
to then you start to understand like oh
cut you know every living organism is
capable of cognition oh I need to kind
of broaden my understanding what
cognition is but do you think plants um
like when you when you eat them are they
screaming I don't know about screaming I
think you have to see what I think when
I eat a salad yeah good yeah I think you
have to scale down the expectations in
terms of right so so probably they're
not screaming in the way that we would
be screaming however there's plenty of
data on Plants being able to
um to do anticipation and certain kinds
of memory and and so on
um I think you know what you just said
about robots uh I I hope you're right
and I hope that's but but there's two
there's two ways that people can take
that right so one way is exactly what
you just said to try to kind of expand
their expand their their their Notions
for that category the other way people
often go is uh they just sort of Define
the term as if if it's not a natural
product it's it's just faking right it's
not really intelligence if it was made
by somebody else because it's that same
it's the same thing they can see how
it's done and once you see how it's like
a magic trick when you see how it's done
it's not as fun anymore and and I think
people have a real tendency for that and
they sort of which which I find really
strange in the sense that if somebody
said to me
we have this this sort of blind like
like uh hill climbing search and then
and then we have a really smart team of
Engineers which one do you think is
going to produce a system that has good
intelligence I think it's really weird
to say that it only comes from the blind
search right it can't be done by people
who by the way can also use evolutionary
techniques if they want to but also
rational design I think it's really
weird to say that
um real intelligence only comes from
Natural Evolution
so I hope you're right I hope people
take it in the other the other way well
there's a nice shortcut so I work with
Lego robots a lot now for my for my own
uh
personal pleasure uh not in that way
internet uh so uh the four legs
and uh one of the things that
changes my experience with the robots a
lot is um
when I can't understand why I did a
certain thing and there's a lot of ways
to engineer that
meet the person that created the
software that runs it
there's a lot of ways for me to build
that software in such a way that I don't
exactly know why it did a certain basic
decision
of course as an engineer you can go in
and start to look at logs you can log
all kind of data sensory data the the
decisions you made the you know all the
outputs in your networks and so on but I
also try to really experience that
surprise and that really experience as
another person would that totally
doesn't know how it's built and I think
the magic is there and not knowing how
it works
that I think biology does that for you
through the layers of abstraction yeah
it because nobody really knows what's
going on inside the biological like each
one component is clueless about the big
picture I think there's actually really
cheap systems that can that can
illustrate that kind of thing which is
even like um you know uh fractals right
like you have a very small short formula
in Z and you see it and there's no magic
you're just going to crank through you
know Z squared plus C whatever you're
just going to crank through it but the
result of it is this incredibly Rich
beautiful image right that that just
like wow all of that was in this like 10
character long string like amazing so
the fact that you can you can know
everything there is to know about the
details and the process and all the
parts and everything like there's
literally no magic of any kind there and
yet the outcome is something that you
would never have expected and it's just
it just you know is incredibly rich and
and complex and beautiful